[Music]
hi I'm Joanna so I'm really excited
about today's show because I have
Leonora lo with me
so Leonora you're a radio announcer yeah
you're a beginner competitor and you're
also living with PCOS yeah correct yes
yes so for those of you who might not
know what PCOS stands for it is
basically polycystic ovarian syndrome do
you want to let us know more about PCOS
well PCOS is in short hormonal imbalance
and this actually comes when you have
cysts in your in your ovaries as why has
polycystic ovarian syndrome and and no
one female is gonna have all the
symptoms one shot you're gonna have
different different symptoms that may
affect you so the closest and simplest
way for me to explain it PCOS is a
hormone imbalance in your body okay it
affects women's siting from as young as
15 onwards all the way to whenever
because there's a that's just how it is
with PCOS yeah and the reason why I'm
doing this show today I find it really
important is because I get a lot of my
followers writing in to me telling me
that they're struggling with PCOS no
matter what they do in regards to
workouts or food intake they can't seem
to get their life to be better yeah so
let's get back to your story to begin
with how old did you realize that you
have PCOS and what are the symptoms
first I wanna say I'm not a doctor okay
this like really based on my experience
and how I'm actually dealing with it I
found out I had PCOS about two years
back Wow yeah recent yeah it's actually
pretty recent and and it was all due to
very very irregular periods okay um
getting real with everybody here girls
we have aa menses we on a monthly basis
and at some point I was actually
spotting in between so I would spot in
between my periods which meant it almost
seemed like as if I was having double
periods in her life and that was when I
went
but after finding out from the doctor we
did a hormone test and everything in the
blood test that's how she assessed and
she died knows that I have a PCOS I've
got PCOS but as I think about it and
because it's a good habit that my mom
enforced upon me and forced upon me when
I was younger which is to track your
period you track your period yeah I do
actually
so it's really important that girls
track your periods and she made me do
that the minute I started getting my
menses okay and I remember there was one
point in 1999 I was spot spot slash
bleeding for about four months four
months yeah and I think let's go of it I
mean I that age you you don't know
what's exactly happening to your body
and it just kept going so I thought it
could be just normal yeah now I think in
hindsight is melody way too long yeah
and there was only one short period that
I actually stopped bleeding for a bit
and then it returned so that was when my
mom said okay no no we're gonna get you
to a gynecologist and have you checked
out so I think my my PCOS problems
thought it when I was already that young
okay but you just found out about it two
years ago I found out what it actually
was new years ago that's right and to a
lot of the people that might be watching
right now I know that a lot of girls
when they do strike when they if they do
have PCOS one of the most common
symptoms include weight gain yeah
weight gain is one of the symptoms for
PCOS so there are a number of symptoms
for example you could have really bad
acne
you could have irregular periods you
have sleep apnea some people even have
facial hair issues on their back on
their face and becomes thicker than
usual and some even have issues with
weight loss so yeah that's there's a
number of symptoms in there you're a
huge inspiration because you but you
went from being I would say I want to
say overweight chunky yes correct yeah
chunkier and then
you just went on this incredible journey
and yeah you decided to get into a
bikini competition not just one - twice
and you warned why is it why didn't you
got third place yeah very cool great
yeah it's amazing yeah so how did you
manage to go from being chunkier you
know struggling with losing weight to
this amazing figure right now yeah first
I wanna say we have anybody who's living
at PCOS it's not impossible and as I
mentioned every single person has
different symptoms
so my symptom I won't say that I had
very bad weight gain because some girls
I know that it's really hard for them to
lose it oh yeah it's because of insulin
than being insulin resistant that's one
of the symptoms as well so for for me
mine was not terribly I was not terribly
overweight and it's also because my
lifestyle I was taking care of it
towards my you could say my young adult
life I was already watching the food I
was already exercising but I just didn't
know the right kind of nutrition and
training for the body because everyone's
body is different so I'll say for
anybody who is having issues of weight
loss for PCOS don't give up it is
something that you can you can honestly
prevent but you can manage okay and can
you tell us more about it how how did
you or I mean how do you manage it even
right now I manage it mostly with having
a healthy lifestyle you know that's so
generic but it's very basic it's eating
right for your body training adding more
weight training actually weight training
is really good for ladies with PCOS and
the other thing is getting a right
amount of sleep okay
now this I'm still fixing I'm gonna be
very honest I'm still fixing that one
but let's get into more detail okay so
let's say in a typical week what is your
workout routine like okay
bear in mind once again this is when I
was on prep okay I trained about five to
six times a week all weight training and
I didn't have any cardio in it until to
where it's my competition competition
date
my food wise oh and I do a split for for
me it could be legs then it's a lower
body than his upper body and then it
just alternates between so ladies do not
keep your weight training okay it's
extremely important no it's very
important I'll tell you why because
weight training first of all you're
gonna build lean muscle mass and that's
exactly what I'm aiming to do from here
on the rest of my life I want to try and
get as lean as possible for my body at a
healthy range I don't need to have six
packs like you do I know I like to know
I would like I would say that my abs are
coming out a lot more but it's not
everything it is not everything okay
because to have your abs coming out you
have to be at a certain fat body fat
percentage but that's an odd thing
altogether so come back to the training
of when like how I'm doing so it's five
to six days of weight training and one
day rest or two days rest depending what
my program is on my food I'm gonna be
honest my food is pretty crazy but it's
meant for my body type I manage it with
where it's really on a high-protein side
and good amount so it's low carb medium
fat and high protein yeah that is my
diet a good amount of fiber yep so in
general you would say that you eat a
really clean diet now that I'm off my my
prep and I'm just maintaining I'm doing
almost like a 80% 20% so 80% I'm pretty
much clean yeah I would say nutritious
and well balanced with everything and
ensuring percent I have my cheat or I
have my treat so for someone that is
watching this right now and to them is
like no matter what they do no matter
what they eat no matter how much workout
they do they can't seem to lose the
weight what is your one piece of advice
how can they start to see results I
would say the number one thing is watch
your nutrition nutrition nutrition is
key because training you can't out train
a bad diet you know that I know that
yeah it's impossible no way can you can
you do it so the best thing you can do
for your body and for yourself to start
even for at least a week try looking at
the foods which are better like no
processed foods more stuff that's high
in fiber your fruits good lean meat like
your chicken your fish you can even
throw in red needs
turkey any kind of meat and eating lots
of veggies which is crucial your fruits
take out I would say the best take out
the fried stuff but take out the
processed stuff and lesson on the sugary
drinks okay so sugar really sugar it
just messes up because for my body type
once again PCOS causes you to be insulin
resistant so for me I need to be very
cautious with what I eat the good thing
is I can I can relax a little because I
have a good amount of muscle on me and
muscle we all know will burn a lot more
calories compared to even when you're
just at rest okay
which is why our same weight training
was really important you build the
muscle you built quality muscle hence
your body is able to burn more and also
burn fat more and hence it will not be
so bad when you go ahead and start
eating more carbs or you have treats for
yourself but everything in moderation
everything moderation yeah right yeah
because I can tell you like after my
prep I just man hello let's just eat
whatever do you think that lifestyle has
a lot to do with PCOS
yeah correct is lifestyle PCOS is
managed by your lifestyle but is it um
is it genetic to begin with and then
manage my lifestyle or can someone what
I heard is it can be hereditary but in
my family I don't know anybody who has
PCOS mine became aggravated when I was
younger I'm not too sure because when I
was younger I really did not know how to
take care of myself thanks a lot to the
education system not this in but just
saying that it'll be good if our younger
generation starts to learn a lot more
about their body and nutrition and how
to eat right and even train right for
that matter so I would say that for me
it was all because of lifestyle that
aggravated it and that's when it came
about again the only reason it stopped
and my menses with regular was because I
was using because the doctor then put me
on Dayan 35 which is actually a birth
control pill and that is one way to
balance out the hormones because you
want to balance out the hormones when
you have PCOS and for
some people they start using
prescription drugs which I don't
recommend I always say that it's best to
go in a holistic point of view and
because I do know some people where they
you get into real bad mood swings with
peace forgot that's also one of the
symptoms and depression can sometimes
hit and some girls they because they
have the weight gain they have
everything and then at the same time you
just get hit with mood swings they can
even take antidepressants and that
doesn't really help at all at the moment
what kind of medications or slop
supplements are you currently taking my
supplements are very basic I take my
multi bites I think my protein powder
when I need to that is only when I
really really need to I take my BCAAs my
fish oils my magnesium magnesium is so
crucial and my vitamin C's okay so
pretty much the basic stuff that other
people would yeah well in general that's
what you should be taking because you
just want to round up everything in a
holistic holistic way I'm not taking any
prescriptions whatsoever I did once and
that was also one of the reasons that my
body composition went out for my comp
okay because hormones do play a part in
how you're storing fat and how waters
accumulate in your body right pheromones
are really crazy I know so when they say
your hormonal yeah we good girls are
hormonal okay it's not it's not Playboy
it's for real
how can someone detect if they have PCOS
I mean how would I know if I piss you
and yeah best way if you feel like you
have those symptoms don't diagnose
yourself through Google I'm sure we
would do that best is going get a
hormone test and a blood test and from
there they're going to take a look at
your progesterone levels your estrogen
levels your TS your t4 all that when
they look at that then you would have a
definitive answer as to whether you are
affected with PCOS but I would say don't
fret it's not the end of the world PCOS
is just condition and you can live of it
it's not the end of the world
yeah you can learn to manage it yeah and
it could actually be a very great
wake-up call for a number of people
females especially since this is
actually on the rise because like a lot
of people don't know they have PCOS in
Malaysia is reported more as an
infertility issue mm-hmm yeah so this
could be a great wake-up call for a lot
more people to start getting aware and
be cautious about their body and adopt a
much healthier lifestyle is there
anything that scares you in regards to
PCOS I I suppose one thing that did
scare me before what PCOS sure at the
beginning it was the weight gain and oh
my gosh what's happening to my body
you're confused and then now as I think
further it also affects the chances of
getting pregnant one day and sure I
would definitely want to have a kid at
some point in my life but now it's
almost like okay whatever I yeah I think
about things yeah I don't enjoy it
exactly I don't know how is what's gonna
happen down the line but it did scare me
that oh the one thing the one thing that
God gave you you can't you know yeah
that you can't do let's talk about
things that we can't control but what
you're doing right now with your life
and you know basically you're living a
life because you're conscious about it
yeah very odd yeah exactly and you're
making changes and you're living a great
life a happy life a healthy life yeah so
what can we expect from Leonora let's
say one or two years down the road are
you expecting to go on and sign up for
more bikini competition like that I
would like to do another bikini
competition down the road not sure when
now I doesn't want to relax and eat food
with friends like now we can go for
waffle I know how unhappy healthy waffle
yeah for now I definitely do want to
look at another bikini competition down
the road that's gonna be another goal
altogether but for now I would say is
just looking at work focusing on how
else actually I want to focusing on how
else I can help reach out to females
that
and guys even who who need to understand
more about their bodies great so that's
my one of my main goals my mission in
life right now is to get people to
understand their body as much as they
can
yeah or at least get them started to be
aware in this millennial Instagram age
where you're just like this most of the
time yeah I know right thank you so much
for coming over
oblems yeah it's been a really great
chat I learned so much just from you and
so if you want to find out more about
Lenora do check out her YouTube channel
her Instagram page and also Facebook
page there are so many videos that you
have shared in regards to PCOS and also
your journey more on my on my journey on
how I got into the bikini competition
but there'll be more me talking about
PCOS and other things in on how to adopt
a healthier lifestyle yeah so go ahead
hop on to her youtube channel click on
the video and just watch the amazing
transformation ok thank you so much cue
huggers thanks for having me thanks